as soon as you put yourself online you
opening up their playing field people to
talk about you in any way and if it's
positive or negative
the Internet has you come on now like me
so many people was unless you have to
call the police
your boobs look like slippers you're too
young for your boobs to be that saggy
undesirable man jaw disgusting
pig nose you clearly a man Chinese [ __ ]
slit eyes [ __ ] eyes fat hole shut up
with my acne scars people said that I
looked dirty using a platform to share
photos that you've taken a person quite
difficult at age 18 I wasn't really
considering having a boob job I started
really thinking maybe it's true maybe I
do need to change myself I never used to
think there was anything wrong with me
and now I'll pick myself apart all the
time it's abusive sometimes I do get a
really upset you can't help but feel
emotionally attached to the internet the
reason why I was getting so much abuse
is because I had been put onto a fat
hating forum which was completely
dedicated to tearing me apart
telling me you can block me but I've got
another 70 profiles and I'll just keep
coming I lost my hearing a year and a
half ago suddenly in my right ear
I've had people attack wearing a hearing
aid saying that I'm a deaf [ __ ] but
imagine I listened to those hate
comments I wouldn't be here with Glamour
magazine having to deal with intrusive
humans on the internet learning a lot of
skills to do with speaking up for
yourself and understanding that they are
fighting a much larger delimit but no
matter what you do there's always gonna
be someone that's going to nitpick it
and they're projecting that onto other
people then I really do feel sorry for
them living for the real moments and not
the online moon and we don't have to
prove ourselves to anybody in order to
feel beautiful
I think women supporting other women
online is the most important thing we
can have negativity turns people into
online chrome campaigns like this hash
tag blend up building can help so many
people out there
[Music]